so it's good to see everybody in in this
manner so thanks for coming for my
session so for the next 1 hour I'm gonna
go through we feel a very interesting
topic and that is deep learning so over
the past few few few months or few few
years you have been hearing all these
words all this battle it's a artificial
intelligence machine learning deep
learning but what exactly are all these
technologies in particular I think for
the past one or two years you have been
hearing about this topic called deep
learning so what is deep learning how
does it affect the way you write your
applications what are the possible
applications of deep learning so in this
next 50 minutes or so I'm going to
unravel the the mysteries behind deep
learning and hopefully at the end of
this session you have a better idea of
how deep learning work and hopefully
you'll be able to to be inspired to
actually try out deep learning yourself
so so let's get started so by the way my
name is waning so if you are if you need
to contact me at the end of this session
please feel free to send me an email and
then if you if you want to know what
other things that I'm doing at this
moment feel free to vote and visit my
website so let's talk about a genderfest
and and let's see what we learn the
things that we'll be covering for the
next 1 hour
so first of all we will talk about deep
learning what is deep learning as
compared to the other broad atoms like
artificial intelligence machine learning
so and so forth so in particular you
will learn how neural network works so
what is a neural network what are the
various layers inside a network so we
will talk about this concept known as
width and biases how do you train them
and you also learned about this concept
known as activation and loss functions
what are the different types of
activation and loss functions and and
which to choose and last but not least
we'll talk about how to use the various
optimizes available so that you can
actually do what we call a back
propagation to update the weights and
and and biases so that you can improve
the performance of your neural network
so these are the things that we will be
talking about for the next 50 minutes or
so
now once the theories of the way we will
have some live demos so in particular
I'm super excited to show you how you
can actually build your own neural
network using tensor flow and care us so
for those of you who are new to this
topic tensor flow and caris they are
both frameworks from Google that allows
you to build deep learning network deep
learning models very easily so that you
can train them you can use them for
predictions so in particular I will show
you how to use the MDS data set for deep
learning how to train using our own
images so I'm gonna show you a deep
learning model that allows you to
actually differentiate between a banana
and orange is probably so strawberry and
and some of the fruits so I will show
you a demo of how to do that and then we
will make use of our webcam to actually
do the recognition so so I have an
orange here so layfon let's see whether
it can recognize our orange successfully
so we will also talk about how to
actually export your tensorflow model to
the tensorflow
light model so that you can actually use
your model that you have already built
to run on mobile devices now in
particular I will show you two demos in
which you can actually use the
tensorflow
light model to run on your mobile
application so if you have an Android
device get rid of your Android device
I'm gonna show you a link where you can
actually download the apk you start it
on your phone and then you can try along
with my demos okay so if you have an
Android device go ahead and grab one if
this is not power up make sure that you
touch it up so that by the time I show
you the link you will be ready to
actually download and install the app
okay so for this particular talk I have
about 60% theory and I have about 40%
demos so for the next 40 minutes or so
I'm going to talk a little bit about
theory so make sure that you stayed
focused so there are a lot of topics
that we can run through now so before we
go any further so let me or rather
should I say ask yourself this question
is this session for you now if you are
already an expert in deep learning then
probably this session is not for you
because you already know all the the
fundamentals about deep learning so go
and grab your beer and and probably it's
too early to have beer if you're in
Europe and especially in Copenhagen so
if not please enjoy now before we
actually go into the gory details of
deep learning so it is important for me
to clarify this very important thing now
deep learning is a huge topic it's a
humongous topic so it is not possible
for me to explain everything in an hour
so it usually takes a semester long
course to cover just the fundamentals so
if you have taken a course in AI or in
deep learning in your university causes
so you typically would have spanned
about maybe a couple of months just
covering the the fundamentals and I am
going to cover them in 30 minutes so I'm
gonna run through a lot of theories with
you all right I think the important
thing to note is I'm gonna focus on the
how and not the why okay so researchers
they have devoted their life time into
researching all the mathematical
explanation for all the theories that
maybe I will present so it's not fair
for me to just use 30 minutes to it to
explain all those concepts so we will
focus on how deep learning books and
then I'll live to you to explore the
details on your
okay now let's demystify three terms
that we always encounter so the first
term is AI artificial intelligence
hey so AI so what is AI so AI had is a
term that has been overused to a lot of
people are talking about air today and a
lot of schools are focusing on AI
teaching kids on how to learn what is AI
one of implications of the AI in their
life so and so forth
so basically AI is basically a program
there can sense reason and adapt so it's
just the process in the broadest sense
of the word so anything that can act
like a human being
that can be classified as AI now with an
AI itself you have just branch of data
science known as machine learning so
machine learning has been the focus of a
lot of research for the past maybe four
well I would say maybe 20 30 years so
machine learning is basically
statistical learning so for those of you
who have taken statistics in your high
school you know what is linear
regression logistic regression so as a
forth or support vector machines all
this are machine learning so machine
learning is basically finding patterns
in your data so you have so companies
today collect a lot of data and when you
call it a lot of data you want to be
able to analyze them you want to see
certain patterns like for example you
collects data about your delivery trucks
your vehicles and you want to be able to
predict when this vehicle is gonna break
down so machine learning allows you to
do just that
make some predictions based on the data
you have collected now with in machine
learning itself you have this super
exciting branch of machine learning
known as deep learning and that is the
focus for this session we'll talk about
deep learning so one is actually deep
learning
so basically deep
uses what we call neural networks so
basically you take one chunk of data and
you try into deep learning algorithms
and the role of a deep learning
algorithm is to help you establish what
is the relationships between the input
and the output and magically deep
learning can actually helps you to
actually solve a lot of real-life
problems such as facial recognition I'm
going to show you that now so there is a
very interesting question that we always
ask people always ask a eye are we there
yet
so are we are we already there so the
interesting thing is that if it looks
it's not AI so unfortunately I think we
are still working towards that that goal
of having a machine that can predict
perfectly as the way a human being would
predict as you will see later on so even
though we tried a lot of different
techniques to actually train our models
sometimes our model will still make some
wrong predictions so I'm going to show
you that later on now so let's go into
the main topic of this session what is
deep learning so generally speaking deep
learning is a machine learning method
that takes an input X and predicts an
output Y okay so that's pretty
straightforward so so let me show you
this diagram so deep learning basically
takes in inputs takes in the output and
the magic is in the middle layer so in
the middle layer it basically tries to
find the relationships between your
input and your output and that is deep
learning and deep learning uses neural
network to accomplish its goal so let's
take a look at what is a neural network
now this term neural network sounds
really sophisticated is
they always say that this is basically
the way the human brain works right but
actually it is not that complex so let
me show you a diagram now don't be
fooled by this diagram this diagram even
though it looks complicated is actually
very simple to understand let me explain
so in a neural network you have your
inputs so on the left hand side so if I
can look at the screen on the left hand
side you have your or your notes
and all the adolescence is your input
layer so the input layer has got all the
various notes here so this is known as
the input layers the input notes now on
the right hand side is your output note
so this is where you actually make your
prediction and in the middle between the
input layer and output layer this is
your neural layers and your neural layer
you can have one layer or you can have
ten layers or you have 20 layers as many
as you need to solve your problem ok so
how does all this work let me give you
one very simple analogy so this is one
example of a input and the output so
suppose you want to train a deep
learning model to differentiate between
a cat and a dog so in this case your
input would be a series of images of
cats and dogs so for the first image for
example in this case it's a dog it's a
dog so imagine that this is a image of
28 by 28 pixels so what we'd like to do
is we might want to flatten this into a
784 pixel representation and we take
that 784 pixels we fit it into the
inputs because we know that this is a
dog so we indicate you know output that
this is a dog and what goes on here is
that between the input layer and output
layer you try to train the network so
that you can actually know that based on
this pattern of pixels this is a doc and
then once you are done with that you go
on to train the next picture so you put
in another dots picture you train okay I
get the numbers and then you have
trained using a cat and at the end of
the whole training you have a set of
magical numbers that will allow you to
mix some really really cool predictions
okay sounds complex I'm gonna show you
by diving into the details into the
various layers so let's define some
coming ologist so I have my input layer
I have my output layer so in between is
what we call the hidden layers the
hidden layers right you can have as many
as ten or twenty or s us one so that's
that's alright now the next important
term that we need to understand is what
call width and biases so what are they
now let's go back to this diagram let's
go back to this diagram now it's
starting to get a little bit complicated
but rest assured it's quite easy to
understand now let's take a look at the
screen here each input node is connected
to the next note in the next layer and
in fact they are all interconnected we
call this a in a fully connected Network
so each connection each connection they
have a weight so in this case I have a
weight of of a certain value so is the
next node that connects to the next node
in the input layer in the next layer so
I have all the bits here now in the
hidden layers each note also have a
value each node has got a value so let's
do
new terminologies now so the numbers
that accompany each connection is known
as the weight so each connection has got
a weight and each note has got a bias so
you have a set of weights and biases so
in short the goal of the neural network
is to basically learn the set of magical
widths and biases so that you can make
very accurate prediction so based on
your inputs like your cats and dogs
images you are trying to learn this
magical set of numbers that's what
you're trying to do so now initially all
these numbers all this width and biases
they are randomized they are randomized
meaning when I first start with this
before I start the training I'll
randomly assign some numbers to this
others weights and biases and it is the
role of the training process to adjust
all these numbers such that at the end
of training all these numbers would be
the so called perfect set of numbers for
you to make accurate predictions okay
following me so far now let's move on so
to summarize the goal of the neural
network is to learn the widths of the
network so that the predicted output is
close to the target and and you will see
later on when it comes to training and
depending on how much data you have to
Train it may take from a shot s maybe
two minutes to Train up to a couple of
weeks just to train a model to do some
maybe facial recognition all right so
that is the exciting thing about deep
learning now let's move on now we have
all the various notes and we have all
the various weights and biases what do
we do with all these numbers now first
of all first of all each input
the value of each input is multiplied by
the weight and you sum up all the
products so X 1 multiplied by W 1 x 2 x
w2 so and so for you sum them up you
plus this bias so you multiply your son
device okay and here's one example so
for an example I'm using the example of
the Titanic data set so for those of you
who have went through some Microsoft
presentation they always like to use the
classic Titanic example so in this case
the inputs may be the age of a passenger
the class of cabin that he stays in and
whether he has got X number of siblings
so I take this number the input
multiplied by the weight I take this
input multiplied by the weight I take
this input multiplied by the weight I
plus the bias so I I get a final result
of four point seven four so this is just
one note and then for the next note you
have to repeat the same process so
multiply is sum them up and then plus
the bias
okay so now so this is what happens at
each note once you are done with layer
now before you take the value and
propagate to the next layer you do not
take the final product and just
propagate to the next layer you pass
them through something called an
activation function activation function
and so this is how you excite so after
calculating the product and the sum of
the buyers you fit them into something
called a activation function an
activation function basically transforms
the number that you have passed in into
yet another number and that is the magic
or rather the magical thing about deep
learning so let me show you one example
so in my previous example after
calculating the value for this note I
get four point seven four and I can pass
it into a activation function I can get
another magical number now don't worry
about why did how did before / 74
becomes zero point eight four I'm gonna
explain that to you okay but for this
example it's a b3 number now so what's
the use of activation function so an
activation function basically allows you
to control or normalize the output of a
neural network okay
so this concept of activation function
is a little bit abstract at this moment
and it is always difficult to explain
this in in five minutes but hopefully as
we go along you have a clearer idea now
okay
having explained what is an activation
function I think it is good for us to
look at what are some of the common
activation functions available all right
so this there are three main types of
activation functions one is called the
binary step activation function and the
other one is known as the linear
activation functions usually for deep
learning Network we do not use linear
activation functions because if you use
linear activation functions your deep
learning model simply becomes a linear
regression model alright so in this case
we seldom use linear activation function
now the third type of activation
functions is known as a non-linear
activation function and that is what we
commonly use when we build our deep
learning model let's dive into the
different types of activation function
now the first one is what we call a
binary step function so a binary step
function is very straightforward
so remember after calculating
calculating the value of a node you pass
it into an activation function so that
it can transform to another number so in
this case X is your input that means the
value that you have calculated for node
you pass into activation function in
this diagram if the value that I have
calculated is more than zero it would
return a walk so in this case any input
is greater than zero it will simply
return you a 1 and any input that is
less than zero
it was simply written you a zero okay so
this is known as a binary step function
now so
if you need help to visualize this
binary step function let me give you one
analogy so it is basically like you
place your hand on a kettle so you put
some water into your kettle you start
boiling so while the water is still
relatively cool
not that hot your hand will be dead but
the moment your kettle hits a specific
temperature it becomes too hot for you
to place your hand on the kettle you
will listen up okay so either your hands
on the kettle or your hand is off the
kettle so that is the meaning of a
binary step function now like I
mentioned linear activation function is
usually not used so linear activation
function basically means that whatever I
get from your input I will multiply by a
constant to give you the output so it is
usually not used in deep learning deep
learning new random walks so I'm gonna
skip it for now
no what about non-linear activation
functions now there is one very commonly
use linear activation functions and that
is called the sigmoid activation
function so here is the chart showing
the input and the output
so remember again the x-axis represents
what is being passed into the activation
function and the output is on the y-axis
so if your input is a value that is
positive it will return you a value that
is from 0 to 0.5 to 1 if your input is a
negative value it will return you a
value from 0 to 0.5 now as you can
probably observed the output is from 0
to 1 so this is an ideal candidate to
use when you are trying to perform a
classification problem when you're
trying to find ok how many percent that
this messenger from the Titanic ship
would survive that disaster
because the probability is always from
zero to one so and and and usually we
use this we use this for predicting
probabilities okay so this is the
sigmoid or also known as the logistic
activation function now so usually we
use the sigmoid activation function at
the output layer where you are trying to
predict a specific output as I mentioned
earlier you are trying to predict okay
how many what is the percentage of
survivor
for a particular passenger on board the
Titanic so your answer that you want to
get an output is a value from zero to
one
okay so that is the use of a sigmoid
activation function
now besides the sigmoid activation
function you have something called the
softmax activation function now
something X activation function is very
similar to the sigmoid activation
function except that it is usually used
for probability distribution output so
for example you are trying to detect the
existence of various objects in an image
so passing an image and my neural
network is trying to analyze okay how
what are the various objects in the
image so it can perform the it can
output the following you say okay there
is a probability of 0.7 that it is a doc
the image and there is a probability of
0.2 then this is a cat and there is a
0.1 probability that this is a guinea
pig so in this case you are trying to
distribute the probabilities
and the important thing about softmax is
the three probabilities then you
generate they will all sum up to what so
here is another example so when your
output needs to be a distribution of
probabilities you use the softmax
activation function okay so I hope you
are following with me at this moment
okay now so there are some more
nonlinear activation functions for
example you have the hyperbolic tangent
activation function now if you recall
the sigmoid activation function returns
an output from 0 to 1 so sometimes there
is not sufficient so sometimes you want
to be able to to get an output from
minus 1 to 1 so in this case you use
this hyperbolic tangent activation
function and we usually use them for two
class classification okay
and both hyperbolic tangent and logistic
sigmoid activation function they are
usually used in feed-forward networks so
just bear in mind now besides the
various specific activation functions
that we have seen there is one that is
very commonly in use today and that is
known as the Trello activation function
something interesting so this is known
as the rectified linear unique so
we usually use them in a special type of
neural network known as a convolutional
neural network now because we only have
one I want to talk about deep learning
we don't have time to talk about
convolutional neural network but but let
me just tell you that this is one of the
most important netbook that you need to
know when you are building deep neural
networks for image classification so
later on we have some examples of that
but just let you know convolutional
neural network is a special type of
neural network that specializes in image
classification so what's so special
about random so if you look at the chart
here so on the left is my sigmoid
activation function so I have my my
output from 0 to 1 now the rule looks a
little bit similar except that for
inputs that are more than 0 it is a
linear distribution so it returns you a
linear output now for all the output
that is less than 0 it straight away
returns you 0 so that's how a real
activation function looks like now of
course the mathematics behind it I'll
leave it to you to go and explore why
this is a much better activation
function compared to the others now
there is one problem with the array loop
and that is when the input is less than
0 you see that your output is all met to
0 sometimes that is not really desirable
sometimes you want to be able to get a
slightly negative value so in order to
fix this randal activation function we
have something call the leaky ray loop
and so how does it look like if you look
at the left this is your render on the
right on the left is your end and on the
right is your leaky ray loop so it looks
a little bit on the left
ok so this is interesting but again if
you want you can go ahead and explore
the
Mattox behind all this okay so in
summary in summary we use activation
function at the end of every note every
level every layer so every end of every
layer we will apply an activation
function so that we will take the output
we pass the next layer next layer apply
activation function and then finally we
go to the output layer and at the output
layer you use either a sigmoid
activation function or you use a soft
MEK activation to distribute the
probabilities so here are some examples
so I can have a output layer female or
male so I can use a soft mix to
distribute the probability so that I can
make some predictions as to how many
percent that is female how many percent
this is male or if my output is just a
single note I can use a sigmoid
activation function to convert the
values so that I can get a value from 0
to 1 okay so I hope that is clear ok
let's move on so it looks like I am
running out of time so I'm going to
speed things up a little bit so that I
have time for demos lost function so at
the end of the one cycle we're at the
where you complete all the values you
fit into activation function you get the
value you fit in to the next layer at
the end you want to have a way to
measure your performance how far are you
away from the actual result you need to
evaluate that so that you know whether
your numerator book is completing
correctly if not how do you actually go
back and update the weights and biases
so we use something called a loss
function so if you are solving a linear
regression problem or rather you know
something a regression problem for
example you explain me and Meg want to
predict certain values that is known as
a regression problem you can use the
mean square error loss function and it's
pretty straight forward you get the
expected output you minus the predicted
value you square then you take the
average and that would give
an idea how far are you away from the
truth
of course if you look at this model
would you look at this formula if you
get a value of zero what does it mean it
means that your prediction is spot-on so
you have perfect prediction there's no
need to continue anymore you have the
perfect model okay so the goal is to
minimize the loss function now so the
loss is basically a summation of all the
errors made for each example in training
so it shows you how well the model is
doing for these two sets and unlike
accuracy loss it's not a percentage is a
value so you want to achieve a loss
value as close to zero as possible
and the lower the loss the better your
model
so they are quite a different number of
lost functions that you can use today
and if you are trying to do to solve a
binary classification problem you can
use something called a binary
cross-entropy if you're solving a
multi-class classification problem you
use what we call a categorical cross
entropy loss function and for regression
problem you can use a mean square error
function so what so what what what's the
idea behind entropy worsening of entropy
so here's an example so an entropy it's
basically a lot lost so what does it
mean so if you're true labor is one so
for example you're trying to predict the
value of something and the true value of
that tree the true value of the output
is 1 but you predicted that this output
is 0.1 so what does it mean it means
that your loss is very very high if you
look at my microcell if if the true
value is 1 and you predicted this to be
0.1 and so when you move up you're gonna
be penalised with a relatively big lost
whereas if the true labour is 1 and you
predicted that this is 0.9 so if you let
0 by 9 so your loss is very very little
and the smaller your prediction the
higher your loss so cross entropy is
basically a way to actually penalize
your your your your your your lost okay
so the higher the loss the the smaller
the loss the better performing your
model is so I hope that is clear ok now
so let
Samuraizer so activation function you
use it at every layer and then at the
final layer you use a loss function so
that you can know okay at this layer at
this layer I want to know how well my
model is performing if it is not
performing then I can actually go back
and update the weights now which brings
us to the next important topic optimizer
optimizer I actually have some detailed
slice to show you how to do back
propagation but I think because of time
constrain
I'm gonna give everybody that the slice
and then you guys can actually go and
explore the slice on your own I'm gonna
save some time so they can show you some
demos ok so but but basically what is
the optimizer so now that you have
calculated the loss what do you do with
that you know that your model is
performing this well or this badly huh
what what do you do with that you want
to use an optimizer to go back and
adjust the weights and biases so out
migration algorithms are used to update
rates and biases and to reduce the error
so there are three commonly used
optimizes one is the SDG for chestie
gradient descent next one is Etta great
that one is Adam okay so you update the
width through a technique known as back
propagation so the back propagation how
does it work so look at this diagram
here so at the end of the at the end of
the the first round so after calculating
all the values you predicted that the
value is zero point one three but there
actually is one so you are quite well
far off from the the expected output so
in this case you need to be able to go
back to the weights and the biases you
need to adjust them so that you can
actually reduce your lost okay make
sense so this technique is known as back
propagation and and using back
propagation the network can actually
backtrack through all its layers to
update the weights and biases of every
node in the opposite direction of the
loss function now I have a series of
slides to explain to you how back
propagation works so basically you can
express them as a loss function and then
you can I should plot the a curve to
show how a loss function looks like let
me see whether I have time to run
through all this because okay I think I
can try that okay so let's look at this
chat so on the x-axis is your weight and
on your y-axis is your lost so if you go
back to this write your input vectors
your input x the set of weights would
give you the predicted output and you
have your expected output here and the
difference between this predicted output
and
the target output is known as the lost
value and I would be able to express
this lost value as a function of the
weight and I can plot a chart that looks
like this okay and if you look at the
chart here we aim to go at the minimum
so we're gonna minimize our lost so that
our deep learning model would be as
accurate as possible so let me show you
one example so let me just show you an
example so I have the following inputs
x1 x2 and I have the expected output in
this case we are doing a regression
problem so what we are trying to do here
is that we are trying to build a deep
learning model so that we can take this
input for five and we try to find the
relationship between four and five and
the output six and so this is my graph
my graph looks like this I have my input
I multiplied by my weights so I can
calculate my output here now for
simplicity I'm living out the bias so
I'm living on the bias so III right but
if you were in the buyers they did it
doesn't really affect the calculation so
and the output is here and this is your
loss value so the loss value is equal to
Y hat minus y square
now so I can initialize my initial
weights remember the initial weights are
all randomized so I put in some values I
multiply them I get my last value and
what when UNIX so I said a formula so I
have y hat I have y hat equal to X 1
with 1 plus X 2 with 2 and I can express
my loss as Y hat minus y square so I get
this formula now I can take a partial
differential so I can calculate a dld Y
hat D Y hat D wit 1 dy handy way to so
again get all these values I can get all
these values now what is the
significance of the oldest values I can
plug it back into the graph so my D Y
hat the weight 1 is here so what does it
represent it represents the rate of
change of Y hat with respect to with 1
so it basically means the amount of wit
1 that new change will affect the
predicted Y same goes for this part here
where you have the D Y hat D with 2 so
it basically signifies the rate of
change of Y hat with respect to the week
2 and finally you have this dld Y hat so
that is the rate of change of the lost
value with respect to Y hat and using
the SGD method this stochastic gradient
descent method you could actually update
your weight w1 w2 with the following
formula so you have the new weight 1
equal to 1 minus the learning rate
multiplied by the rate of change of the
lost value with respect to weight 1 so
so to reduce the lost you just need to
move your weight one in the opposite
direction from the derivative hence you
have a - ok so
until leaf needy slice for everybody so
that you guys can actually take a look
at it later on and trace true it's a lot
of math I I understand so let's take a
look at so to complete with one you have
to plug in all the values or the
formulas that you have and then at the
end of the calculation you get a new
value for week one and you perform the
same thing for the wit - and at the end
of the whole calculation you get a new
value for week two and then so now
you're ready to tuck it back in to this
graph and you repeat the same process
for the next row okay okay so I know
it's a lot of things to digest in this
short amount of time and I think I am
going to jump straight into demos
because there are a lot of things I want
to show you so I'm gonna sleep skip this
for now okay so in summary you use
activation at the end of every layer and
then empty and you use your loss
function and your optimizer to actually
backtrack to update the weights and
biases okay demo and I think this is
what everybody is ready for now to build
deep learning models you can you have a
number of choices you can use the
tensorflow and caris frame book from
google or you can use the pi torch from
face book so but for this example I'm
gonna use tensorflow
and Cara's so tensorflow is an open
source library for numerical computation
and deep learning and the problem if
tensorflow is that it goes down to a
very low level involving fact vectors
tensors so so forth so it's not easy for
beginners to do to use so the
an engineer from Google actually brought
a rapper call Karis to wrap around Texas
law so that you don't have to do with
the low-level details and that is the
use of chaos now so the first demo that
I want to show you is this so what I
have here is that I have a Python
program that input the a classic data
set used for deep learning learning and
it's called M nice data set so let me
just show you how it works first so I'm
gonna run this so he's gonna go through
the entire program and so it's importing
the libraries so so at this point it is
clear that this is a set of images the
emmys data set is the set of images
representing all these handwriting's
okay all these handwriting's and
hey so let's continue so I am importing
all the images and then I'm doing the
training so so the training actually
went on I have created a model with the
following layers and then because the
training went on quite fast so as you
can see that I have a number of epochs
the number of epochs means for the
entire training set how many times do
you want to subject this whole training
set for training so I'm gonna strain
this for 50 times so I'm gonna stick my
whole set of images repeat this 50 times
so as you can see you can you have a lot
updating of the weights so as I train I
get the accuracy I get the accuracy so
initially it's 0.62 and then right
through the end I get a 92% accuracy and
once I've done that I can evaluate my my
model with my test set and I can plot a
chart to show the accuracy and I can
load a sample image and see how it how
well it predicts so so far so good so it
is able to predict this very nicely now
towards the end after running through
the whole model I want to save it as a
h5 file so I want to save the train
model so that I can actually use it
somewhere else I could also export this
as a tensorflow
like model and I'm gonna show you a
example that I had written there you go
so I have taken this model I have
trained and I have exported it to
tensorflow light and using flutter I
have created this application that
allows me to a basically scribble on my
phone so I can try something like this
to recognize it recognizes - not too bad
okay and then 9 and I have scribble 0
there you are format to bet so that is
the first demo that I want to show you
now the second demo is interesting
second a most interesting
let me show you what I have up here now
I have a set of images that I want
trained so I am creating a deep learning
model specifically I'm creating a CNN a
convolutional neural network to help me
recognize images so what are the images
on train train I'm trying to free my
mother to recognize images like bananas
durians
okay oranges as well as strawberries so
I'm going to run it so I'm gonna run
this so it will go ahead and look at my
images
and okay so it's a string now so it is
basically looking at all my images and
trying to analyze trying to build a deep
learning model to do recognize images so
okay let's get a couple of seconds I
think this is going to be pretty fast so
I only set the training tool to run for
15 i box as you can see if you have
images is gonna take a longer time to
train so it also depends on your
resolution of the images as well as the
number of images you have for each
category
you
Hey
so I have a question and I think
somebody is asking what number if it's a
picture transform to so it depends on
what kind of network you're building so
basically you won't even have images you
basically takes the individual pixel of
the image and a lot of times we
basically transform that into a value
from 0 to 1 so we basically normalize
that but in in a CNN you can actually
load a colored picture and then you have
a 3 channel RGB channel and then you run
through a series of what we call futures
ok so so basically in short we deal with
the pixels of the image so I hope I've
answered a question and I mean that's
one question on slide oh okay so once
we're done with that okay so let's see
how well our deep learning model
performs so you look at this so this are
all my test pictures this are the
pictures that I have not used for
training so the my deep learning model
has never seen all these pictures so I
will run this and so it predicts that
this is a banana okay so so far so good
this is a durian okay this is a
strawberry so that's good banana this is
a durian moon so what's a bit this is a
banana banana this is a durian as you
can see I'm a big big fan of the orange
this is a durian durian this is a
strawberry so far so good this is a
strawberry
ah what about if you have a mixture of
strawberries in bananas so in this case
it returns you some probability and you
say hey maybe the number of strawberries
in this peaches too overwhelming so it
predicted that this is a strawberry so
you can compare the probabilities and
and the next one
durian okay then take define that's fine
banana durian and then do really and
then this is in orange orange not too
bad not too bad so so you can see that
the the accuracy of this is on the back
not a bear now I have trained this model
it would be more fun to actually use a
live picture so I'm gonna do that
so that's give me one second I'm gonna
switch off the video so that you won't
see me but you'll see my screen right so
I'm gonna do that
okay so just once again I am loading the
application
okay bagel
banana okay so I am going to show you
some pictures
so unfortunately I don't have a deuteron
to to to show you right now so I am
going to show you some pictures I have
on my phone okay so I'm gonna put this
and a strawberry so that's the spring
[Music]
but neither okay I'm gonna lower the I
think it's too bright
okay banana and then Julian okay let me
see do I have an okay so let's try the
strawberry one more time
okay not too bad not too bad okay so so
let's let me just go back okay so that
is the second demo that I want to show
you so you are able to train a CNN to
recognize images you can you can also
train CNN to recognize faces as well
although that requires a little bit more
effort but you can do that using CNN now
Lister the one that I'm gonna show you
is using some pre train models some pre
train models so imagenet is basically a
repository of all the images that they
have collected and they run all these
competitions every year and they invite
researchers to actually submit models
that allows that to solve all those
image recognition problems so here are
some of the common image net pre train
models that you can actually use to
recognize different types of objects so
in this case I can use a BG 16 inception
v3 ResNet mobile next sample should run
true so when I run this it will
basically download the train model from
the D website the Charis website
tensorflow website and
so at least it's still loading but what
I want to show you here is that it is
able to actually help you predict given
an image one is the object in the image
so it's pretty accurate
so this is moving okay so it's moving
it's moving okay David so vgg 16
basically tells me that this is a banana
and it also tells you there this might
be a hook or a slug or a half or a
flatworm so this is the result from all
the other three twin netbooks then you
can actually use okay now I think my
time is running out so I just have one
final demo that I want to show everybody
so you can also use this in your mobile
application so I can select a photograph
and I can select it let's say a picture
and you would tell me the hey this is a
car and then if I select another photo I
can select a birthday cake it tells me -
hey this this is the cake and I can
select something else like let me see
fruit and interestingly it recognizes
that this pie point is is a banana ok so
remember for AI if it works it's not AI
okay so I think this is what I have the
time available for me okay so so you can
ask the questions on sly dog
so let me okay so these are the
questions I have received now somebody's
asking we perform as good with different
backgrounds then white yellow background
for banana so know if in fact if you
have a white background and with the
image in front that would actually
perform better so so the key thing is
that you you should keep your background
as clean as possible
it doesn't have to be white but as long
as it doesn't interfere with the object
in the foreground that will be good
enough
more questions
so I'm gonna make all this lights
available so I'll be posting the link to
slack so if you want the slice you can
actually go to the slack discussion
group and then you should be able to
find it if you don't see that just send
me an email and I'll be more than happy
to email you that slide deck any more
questions
okay if no questions thank you very much
I hope to see you again hopefully in
person or the next and this event
thank you very much